you should make like an insane price
prediction right now on bitcoin
what why not we're at 107 likes
we're at 107 likes before we go to
commercial if we jump to 150 likes
i will uh i'll tell you what i think's
gonna happen later this year
all right like it i like it i already
like smash the like button
smash that like button i don't think
that we're gonna get there so
i mean there's 470 people watching 115
likes no i think that's going to exist
there was a situation where the power
went out i was holding 37
145. here we go
done done let's hear it let's hear it
i've been trying not to do this in 2019
i wrote a piece that said bitcoin was
going to hit 100k
i've never waffled and when it fell i
just bought more there's a
very low chance in my mind we don't hit
100k this year i'm more impressed that
you found a way to use the word waffled
that was epic do you use like a word of
the day or something i'm an s.a.t guy
all right so 100k i see you're not
paying attention now i'm an act guy
s.a.t words a-c-t
for the scores you think it's gonna you
said in 2019 it was going to hit 100k
by the end of this year yeah in 2019 i
wrote the whole thesis was
uh we were going to get some sort of
market correction at some point i didn't
know when i didn't know what would drive
it but just
we're in the longest bull run in history
there was early warning signs in terms
of the repo markets were gyrating ceos
were leaving at a high pace
um you know there's just a bunch of
issues that you could see uh that it was
all kind of cracking
i did not predict uh global pandemic or
any of that type of stuff but just like
something's gonna push the market over
um and when they did it i said look
they're gonna have to step in and
they're gonna have to manipulate the
market they're gonna have to print money
they're gonna have to
manipulate interest rates down uh and
when they do that if it happens in some
period of time
around the bitcoin having it's gonna be
an absolute explosion for a price and i
think exactly words i used was
rocket fuel for bitcoin in 2019 i said
it was rocket fuel for bitcoin i wrote
about it i believe
in may of 2019 and again in july of 2019
that the rocket fuel for bitcoin was
going to be that when the market turned
over
regardless of what caused it they were
going to step in they were going to drop
interest rates they were going to
uh print more money than they'd ever
printed before with quantitative easing
and it was all going to coincide around
the same time that the bitcoin having
happened
and so right when they manipulated the
legacy market people would run
and they would look for a hard asset uh
like bitcoin
and right as you get that demand shot
because people are running to it you're
gonna get a supply shock where you're
gonna go from
uh 1800 bitcoin a day coming into the
market to 900 bitcoin with bitcoin
having in may 2020.
it's exactly what happened and the price
exploded we went from 8 000
on the day of the bitcoin having all the
way up to eventually went up to 64 000
uh obviously it's corrected a little bit
but i still think that we will end up
hitting 100k by the end of 2021.
you